Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday
So Hannah Hart asked people who donated to her kickstarter to show off their kitchens because she might come cook in them
[Henry:] Daddy?  [John:] Yes?  [Henry:] Are you hungry?
[John:] I'm not hungry are you hungry?  [Henry:] Yeah  [John:] I am too.
I was lying before.  [Henry:] Me too.  [John:] Alright, we should eat some dinner
So, we're gonna cook dinner and show off our kitchen for Hannah Hart!
Do you think we should start with a drink?  [Henry:] Umm, okay!
[John:] How about fresh squeezed grapefruit juice? [Henry:] No!
[Henry:] How about we make grapefruit juice. [John:] You wanna make grapefruit juice?
[Henry:] Yeah [John:] I'm listening. I'm into it, let's try it.
Alright, Henry, what is the first step in making grapefruit juice?
[Henry:] What? [John:] We have to get-   [Henry:] Grapefruit  [John:] That's correct!
[Henry:] Who does cutting with sharp knives in this family? [Henry:] You.
[J:] That's right, who doesn't?
[H:] Mama.
[J:] No, it's you. Who-, by the way who is the better cook? Is it daddy or mommy?
[H:] Umm, you. [J:] That's just not accurate.
[J:] Whoa!!
Every great meal starts with a grape juice.
You wanna have a little bit of grapefruit juice and then you wanna spike it.
[Henry:] And then you wanna spike it? [John:] I  recommend spiking with water.
Mmmm
[John:] Mine is delicious, how is yours? [Henry:] Sour!
So Hank, once you have your first cocktail, you're ready to start cooking and in our house that means... what's for dinner?
Macaroni and cheese.
With a side of whatever we can find in the fridge.
[Henry:] No I don't! [John:] Everybody likes asparagus. [Henry:] But I don't. [John:] Really? It's like the fruit of the sea, but it's from land.
[Henry:] I don't like it. [John:] Hmm. Alright, let's see what we've got here.
Oh, leftovers are always promising. But that appears to have kale so that's out.
Alright, so we've got asparagus, mild cheddar cheese, celery, blueberries, sweet potato fries, mac and cheese, and tortillas.
This is gonna be great. But, we're missing one thing. [Henry:] What? [John:] Blueberry muffins.
Okay, step one: Feed your kid a blueberry muffin because you should have served him dinner like 30 minutes ago
but you were screwing around with grapefruit juice.
Then you're going to want to heat six cups of water for your macaroni
and you know, like a regular amount for your asparagus.
Now Henry, experts will tell you to wait until the water is boiling,
but I am not cooking for experts, I am cooking for a 3 year old.
So you can really throw the asparagus in at any time you want.
Pro tip: put your iPhone underneath the washed asparagus?
You take the celery and then add like peanut butter and raisins and then it's called ants on a log
[Henry]: No. [John]: No? [Henry]: I don't want peanut butter on it
[John]: You don't want peanut butter on it? [Henry]: No! [John]: What are you, a communist?
[Henry]: Uhm... Yes! [John]: You are? [Henry]: Yeah. [John]: That's a surprise.
[John]: But you know what, I'm just happy that you're politically engaged at your age
[John]: I think that's great
At this point you want to start plating your freshly washed blueberries, your communist celery
Meanwhile, you get your asparagus started
And now is when you give up on the idea of cheesy tortillas, which, let's face it, was a terrible idea in the first place. Agreed?
[Henry:] Yeah. [John:] Put the sweet potato fries in the microwave for maximum sogginess,
which is how Henry likes them,  and have a drink. 'Cause you're getting there. Ah. Sour.
Pro tip - so, the best way to know that your asparagus is done, is when you're bored and you don't want to wait
anymore to eat it. Also, don't forget to put your macaroni on the wrong stovetop so that it never actually boils.
Take out the asparagus, that water is finally boiling. You don't want it al dente. [Henry:] No.
[John:] You want it soggy. [Henry:] Yes. [John:] You and I are on the same page, buddy.
[Henry:] Yeah. But I want cheese on it. [John:] Yeah, soggy and cheesy. Once your pasta's good and cooked,
you take it from there, and you put it in the little strainer thing. Ahh, this is where it can all go wrong.
But it all went right. Then you add your milk. Yes! Oh, it just looks delicious. [Henry:] And I'm done!
We have to st-stir it. [John:] And at last, you add in the pasta! [Henry:] Pasta!
[John:] Then, plate and enjoy. So, Hank, and Hannah, that's how Henry and I make dinner together
here in Indianapolis. DFTBA. I'll see you on Friday.
Say DFTBA. [Henry:] DVFTVA? [John:] That's pretty good.